Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this segment are celebrating the new
year with the new Clinic Rocky talked
with the doctor to find out more
hi my name is Gilda jabrazada I go by Dr
Gilda and today we're here at Sunset
Maiden in Henderson Nevada this is a
brand new Clinic that opened last month
on December 5th 2022 and we're very
excited to start and see new patients a
lot of people may not know what a myogen
clinic is so imagine Clinic is basically
a clinic tailored to the senior citizen
population who is 65 and above will have
Medicare insurance plans now you can be
any type of Medicare whether straight or
Medicare Advantage patients should not
worry about that if they ever have any
questions they can always call their
office and we can run their insurance
for them so in addition to just being a
senior Clinic we do specialize in
certain testing that are screened
towards most prominent conditions in the
geriatric population for example at our
Clinic not only do we have an on-site
lab where it's more convenient for the
senior citizen population to get their
labs done either prior or after due to
their appointments we have some thing
called the quantum flow machine which
basically screens for purple vascular
disease in addition to that we also have
another machine another tool that helps
us to screen patients for neurop of
neurometrics in addition to having these
tools in the clinic we do offer you know
Road basic annual Wellness exams routine
follow-ups post-op eval and pre-op evals
as well as Hospital discharge well the
practice of the My Generation clinics is
preventative medicine which includes
annual visits Health screenings and so
it's very important for this population
especially you know the patients with
Medicare insurance plans to schedule
their annual Wellness exams with their
providers in the beginning of the year
where we discuss extensive Health
screenings such as screening for
osteoporosis cancers diabetes heart
disease many of the major prominent
diseases out there now we do this via
lab tests Imaging as well as a referral
to specialist for further tests we also
screen for mood disorders such as
depression and anxiety as well as
cognitive impairment which is also
unfortunately very prominent in senior
citizen population we also Ensure that
they're not at risk for false if they
need anything such as Home Health we do
also have care workers and social
workers that also help patients to
utilize the resources that we offer
finally we also screen to see if the
patients do have access to food shelter
and water especially you know as we all
get older it is a little bit difficult
to take care of yourself to cook for
yourself so we do have resources such as
Meals on Wheels which deliver already
cooked meals to the patients
um so you know overall I think it's very
important that the patients set their
number one goal
um to schedule a annual wellness exam
with the providers
[Music]
and health for sponsoring this segment
for more information you can visit
intermountainnv.org Las Vegas now we'll
be right back
[Music]